breaking news from president biden's
trip to asia in a news conference with
the japanese prime minister mr biden
indicated that the u.s will step in to
protect taiwan if the island is ever
attacked by mainland china the president
was responding to a question from our
nancy cordes who joins us now from tokyo
so nancy there's official u.s policy and
then there's the way the president
answered your question good morning
good morning to you and there's no
question that this was a major departure
from long-time
u.s policy and it means that if china
were to make good on its threats to take
over taiwan the u.s could get pulled
into a military conflict with the
world's second largest superpower
they're already flirting with danger
right now the president's warning took
regional allies and even some of his own
aides by surprise are you willing to get
involved militarily to defend taiwan if
it comes to that yes
you are
that's the commitment we made
the idea that it could be taken by force
just taken by force is just not it's
just not appropriate his comments
quickly drew international headlines
for years the u.s has had a policy of
so-called strategic ambiguity when it
comes to taiwan a self-governed island
that china considers its territory a top
chinese spokesman fired back at mr biden
taiwan is purely china's internal affair
he said we won't stand for any foreign
interference the white house sought to
soften the president's stance claiming
our policy has not changed and that mr
biden simply committed to provide taiwan
with the military means to defend itself
as president biden travels through asia
he is being briefed about the spread of
monkey pox with cases now confirmed in
more than a dozen nations including the
u.s some countries are imposing 21-day
quarantines for people who are infected
or even in some cases just exposed
should americans expect something
similar
no i don't think so look we've had this
uh
monkey pox for the larger numbers in the
past number one
number two we have vaccines to take care
of it and so i i just don't think it
rises to the level of the kind of
concern that existed
with covert 19.
the president says he does believe that
the smallpox vaccine could prove
effective in stopping the spread of
monkey pox and he says the nation has a
lot of smallpox vaccine stockpiled but
he says people should be careful until
we know more about the spreadgale
i know we're all trying to figure that
out nancy cordes reporting from tokyo
thank you